we'll wait for some people to get in
here
we're in the open Pilot lounge
all right and Harold's coming over to
join us
he's right around the corner
all right
so Harold's here he's joining us
remotely from his comma body
and we'll go uh
Harold is going to lead us to his office
so this comma body has a hat and
training wheels
it's one of a kind right now
and it's being remotely controlled
nope
if it's stuck now nope
this is the first step in shipping
common security to your comma body
and telepresence
Harold do you want to show us
under the control center
this is the website Harold's been
working on the last couple weeks how
cool is this did you see how smoothly I
made it over here I only got stuck once
yes this is the experiment we've been
working on on the Kama body so uh
you can control the body from uh from a
website we're making and we're gonna
we're just experiment you can come show
the website I guess it's very primitive
right now but we wanted to get some cool
stuff working so you just you know go
live stream you can control
uh you know with the keyboard
just some experiments we've been working
on Tesla bot competitor exactly look at
this doesn't this look so much better
than Tesla bot doesn't have to walk so
you don't get that problem fixed we'll
get you off the hat it kind of looks
like a crown oh yeah I got a little
Crown here that was just for some
localization tracking experiments
unclear what the future that is but you
know the wheels help a lot on the carpet
so
yeah I've been driving around it's
pretty cool we'll see uh we'll see what
comes of it we kind of maybe you can
clean it up and we can uh we can have
some wheel in the store and we'll have
some kind of security uh security
website you can go to you can log into
your body from anywhere to drive around
the office that was kind of the idea
um you know tell me about your dream
what's my dream oh about the the Rover
my real dream is we put the uh
put the the common three on a Mars Rover
and we send it to Mars California which
is a real town in California that looks
like Mars and just you know you can we
can log in from the office and we can
drive our real Mars Rover around
so that's the long-term dream but for
now it's just that enough is security so
uh we'll see how far we get
um yeah what do you got next recipe you
wanna oh we should introduce ourselves
oh yeah but this is the part we forgot
last time we'll do that this time so I'm
Harold I'm CTO a comma been here for a
while
I'm a deep I work on open pilot here at
comma it leaves a charge of open pilot
you know he gets all the PRS merged or
rejected if they're not good so
all right and then let's should we go to
some empty rooms we're hiring for quite
a few positions
right
yes yeah we've got some beautiful
metrics up here oh yeah we've really
been putting in a lot of this engagement
those are really cool metrics are cool
this is something we've been recently
working on
it's uh weishing or driver monitoring
guy made all these so it just kind of
shows all these different classes of
disengagements which is like either
longitudinal or lateral or you know if
it's turning turning too tight not
turning tight enough
whether it's uh you know some kind of
low speed disengagement whether it's
followed by a heartbreak or Excel by the
user so kind of help us narrow down what
people are disengaging for and hopefully
you know fix issues more in a more
directed way yeah and we've got the
controls matcher come on up there you
can compare like your Individual Car
to uh the average of the fleet and you
can kind of see whether uh
how good your car is compared to like
the top open pile experiences yeah I
mean we've been struggling a little bit
sometimes we've got cars that you know
are performing differently and if we
don't have them uh this has been an
issue so far in trying to make them sure
they perform well but with these kind of
metrics we can we can hopefully
understand what's happening even if we
don't own one ourselves
nothing here
so we've got two main rooms that are
open ready for hiring 51 what is this
one in the web room yes this is for the
web team the web team is one person
right now and he works in the open pilot
office
but once it's two people this will be
your room
we're even gonna get a cool neon sign
like that one in here once it's the web
room
um
web three it could be whatever you want
to say
um
and then we've got one more open pilot
office here that's empty
uh this is just for any open about
engineer who wants to come work here
yeah
we can show you guys the main office too
I think we we did stream from here and
then uh this is where the open pile team
works right now
Cameron is on the web team so you'll
join him if you join the web team and
you guys will move over to the web room
all right cool
Hangouts
ready for some chili
all right should we go to the Ford yeah
so what we're gonna do we're just gonna
demo zero in two yes let me talk about
some of the nice UI updates the Ford
yeah sensors
what do you mean that there's bathrooms
[Applause]
we have really good
oh that kind of PR
uh
so you know we've been trying to tackle
some kind of heat issues like the device
with this we can simulate the Sun
uh it should be a full Texas mode or an
abnormal Dubai is
all right we got the Bronco right here
yeah I think it's a better angle
yes
the more information you want to give
about the fourth in general so we're
showing off uh the Ford Bronco sport
this is our personal Ford we have in our
Fleet
um it's new in this release the Fords
are quite a nice platform somewhat
similar to Toyota where they're mostly
the same all the stream quality is like
a potato
I don't know if we can fix that well
even Wi-Fi Realty oh I just switched to
LTE
it's my bars
oh bars look good
still good so yeah I think it's fine
please try F-150 support yeah so the
F-150 is
pretty similar to this one actually the
only difference is it's can't D so it
needs the red panda and the steering
message is different they use like a new
one for blue Cruise
so that one is should be very doable
um one of the tricky parts of that might
be to finding an easy place to install
it
um
we had an F-150 in our office briefly
and uh do you have a route you want to
go on uh
I'll show off experimental
[Music]
I know there's a lot of buttons uh it's
all right again press a bunch of buttons
yeah
all right this is an experiment
experimental mode right yes
okay
so we should see it stop for that
upcoming stop sign
[Music]
you guys might notice the New Path
we call it Rainbow Road
all right
and as soon as we're on the on-ramp the
one accelerates they should turn green
[Music]
but yeah about the Ford platform so we
support six and the initial release zero
nine two that will support them
and uh
we can basically support any that have
the lane centering and aren't can FD
pretty easily you just have to add a
fingerprint essentially
um
full green on the on-ramp yeah that's a
speed up
can you guys see that UI
F-150 without blue cruise but has
adaptive cruise in Lane centering uh
yeah probably
we might put up a bounty for the F-150
because the monkey is also the same
platform
so everything is there for you except uh
it won't steer so if you want a fun
little project you can get a comma three
and uh play around with that it'll like
parse the speed it'll do all that for
you it just won't steer
we'll just Drive North a bit on
experimental mode right and see what
happens yeah let's do it so this is Ford
long that's not shipped yet right yeah
so in zero nine two it's lateral only
the exciting thing about Ford is we
should have the radar and preserve a b
so we should be able to ship uh
longitudinal as a default to release
pretty soon after and then it'll be a
toggle in master I can
like oh it's gonna be yeah
so it should ship the release fairly
soon
yeah the Fords are super nice they're
like the tss2 Toyotas
yeah it's a really good platform maybe
the steering at low speed is really good
how are you guys enjoying zero nine two
so far
to see UI from here
stream quality isn't helping
let me zoom in a little bit yeah I mean
if you can't see it basically so there's
two big changes to the UI that we made
since we added uh foreign
clear indication of exactly what the car
is going to do
it depends long and then the other big
change is if before we used to show the
model predictions of what the model
wants to do and those kind of meant
something
outwards go into like a planning system
with a PC and that outputs the actual
plan that the car will try to drive so
that's what we show now in the UI it's
more smooth and also
too that the path
[Music]
which is
a few questions no questions
we have some other highlights from zero
Knight 2 your device should boot up
quite a bit faster
we've also got a new model in there
trained with a new data set
we're kind of hoping to ship new models
like that fairly frequently that might
not have an impact on you but we feel
very confident about our testing
we should be able to ship refactor and
stuff like that
[Music]
new changes
uh when is 092 being released so it's in
devel right now and it'll be in release
uh it's slated for Monday
is there anything so we're still writing
a blog post anything you guys want us to
discuss in depth in the blog post
is Maverick support
I believe so
you can go on the compatibility page
right now call my I slash vehicles and
that's all up to date
zero thank you
it's a lot of cars
um yeah
coming to bolt with zero nine two below
six miles an hour uh no
but there is some bolt tuning somebody
wants to know what's special about the
Nicki Minaj model
[Music]
but that doesn't mean that it's really
that good at navigating on open pilot
yet it's just kind of an in between
stuff you shouldn't be I think
yes Cameron confirmed the Maverick is
supported if you've got a Maverick you
can head on to the site and you can buy
a device and it'll just work in your
Ford Maverick
the low speed in particular is really
nice so entering long on the Bronco and
the other Fords super nice
20 to 40 miles an hour
oh yeah the other thing when we made the
changes to the MTC
uh drawing we notice a small bug
caused this
in some cases people aren't getting a
little too close to the inside of their
turn because of this and so this is
oh we've got the hiring Banner to talk
about too I forgot about that
so we're going to announce a hiring
Bounty where if you refer somebody
who we hire and keep around for two
months
you'll get a comma three and three
thousand dollars
so if you know anybody refer them
we'll take our challenges we'll
interview
and you can get some money
how close are you all to releasing Taco
drives for production
[Music]
necessary that are not really shipped by
default which is it went long you know
which is an experimental mode right now
and the other is Navigator mobile so
Navigator local pilot is what we're
working on pretty hard right now
[Music]
as soon as you enter
it you'll start using the map as an
input um
to get to that destination so it should
take exits it should try to take turns
but
that sort of stuff
yeah so that's a broken progress I mean
there are branches that do this some
people have been trying them you've been
trying to make you want to kind of see
the progress but we're still figuring
out a few
[Music]
weeks to master
the thing is that this affects all
driving this is a pretty big
architectural change to have the model
also understand maps and to take maps
and input and to rely
on new testament which is why it's
taking so long but yeah we're focused on
where can I find more info on the Bounty
hiring program uh we'll probably tweet
about it maybe Alex will tweet about it
today
um you're all about hiring what's the
salary for a few years of experience uh
I think typically Georgia said in people
ask this if that's your first question
uh might not be for you
um take a look at our challenges if they
look like something that you'd like to
do
let's say try it out
if not it's probably not a good fit
anyway
anybody have hiring questions we'll take
Oak pile questions hiring questions
can I buy an F-150 to add to my C3
uh it won't work out of the box but if
you have any software engineering
experience it should be a very doable
project all you have to do is you know
the message is already defined in the
DBC
I'm not quite sure what's left to do
with that
I think I might be figuring out the
checksum
but it should be pretty straightforward
like maybe a weekend or two weekend kind
of project
all complaints
they're bothering about all pilots and
annoyances please talk about them you
mentioned
on the screen we can now talk about them
and I know one big one is people wanted
us to follow distance the reason that
hasn't happened yet is just you know we
want we want to guarantee that the cars
will slow down in time and accelerate in
time and that's harder to do when uh
there's multiple settings for the car to
be in so that's why it's taking so long
everyone wants it
so follow distance to now and along
customer support engineer role must that
be local in San Diego
I think so but
uh yeah you can email and if you think
you're a strong candidate but
um I mean the bar is kind of high for
all rules
or with
examples does anyone have any complaints
yeah complaints are just as good as
questions yeah
yeah we've got some good thermal
improvements coming in the next release
we're hoping to ship 093 pretty quickly
we know zero nine two took a while it's
kind of a big release
um
093 should be out
kind of on a normal Cadence
what else
we got some good stuff we want to try to
do some UI stuff
where are we uh we want to improve steer
saturated and the minimum steer speed
and kind of show them continuously in
the UI so it should show you it's kind
of deviating and then it's not just a
sudden alert you get um ship expected
and perhaps you take over beforehand you
don't get an alert at all
yeah most people
are coming up that it's not going to be
able to make it and it's kind of
annoying to have to be alerted every
time it's annoying on some of our parts
like the Civic so do that more smoothly
one guy says his Civic ping pong's a
little on the highway if you post in the
Discord a driving feedback Channel
um it'll tell you how to make a good bug
report and then we can look into it
uh no real complaints though I'd love to
see experimental mode for the bolts uh
experimentable exists for the bolts in
non-release branches so you can run
devel or master
also it's it's kind of alpha right
um
yeah I mean if you post complaints on
Discord about like driving behavior may
not necessarily reply to all complaints
but we definitely look at them
would be helpful way
to steer what we fixed
did you see how smooth the steering
wheel is the Bronco is like one of the
best new cars we've shipped in a long
time
one is torque controller steering coming
to the rest of the fleet uh the metrics
that we showed you guys are one of the
first steps to that uh
we've kind of been doing a piecemeal but
we want better ways to evaluate this
part of this that person have it's Jason
so PWS
how many have you know we had this
video have you thought about integrating
mats no we're pretty particular about
this but
one thing new in 092 doesn't affect you
guys who are already users is endog is
the default now
it was
users vastly preferred it about 60 of
people toggled it
and if you don't know the acronym dog
it's no disengage on gas so you can use
the gas pedal to override the toggle is
still there so you can toggle back to
disengage it on gas
um but it's up to you how does the
testing simulation work for testing
end-to-end launch signal experimental
about Behavior
well I mean
so basically this
Empire from its original position
this means
make it slower than it did which is how
we can simulate
it means we have very limited range
you know if you do debtory projection
you move the car forward the model back
while you start getting artifacts so
it's very good at stimulation
Hy that we're not making more progress
on that
soon as we
I mean we're working on machine learning
simulation that should have no limits as
soon as that works we'll get better
tests for internet long and
these are good questions
good questions
uh RAM start Speed yeah only some of
them start at zero
um what can we expect 2023 policy until
you're doing official support list on
Sunny uh
I know it was a big change I'll ask
Shane when we're back
you can always ping Shane if you have
like a some car stuff
um it's always hard to prioritize that
there's so many new cars coming in the
ecosystem
um
once the holdup for nav on op and
experimental mode and master
should be uh directly to a release to
master as the default so as soon as you
put on the map and I mean what's the
holdup that I was talking about a bit
before
um it's just
it's a massive new input that changes
you know everything in driving because
now the model will learn to look at the
map and rely on the map so if the map
has issues this can cause issues so
there's just a lot of tests we have to
write and a lot of verification but yeah
I mean we're working on it there are a
lot of branches that do this if
you can try to show you guys the UI or
at low speed
the New Path
where I got a notification that you uh
unbuck with your seatbelt you see how
the path is green now
I guess that means it's accelerating
yeah and then it's gray
[Music]
it's green again
and it's cool because it shows you how
much it wants to accelerate at which
point in the path before it was one
color and it wasn't very stable
it was just squint your eyes uh sorry
guys we'll get better out of this uh
it's already a bit better than last
stream
yeah we're not very good at the
streaming stuff but we're learning
it's like everything else we do
iterate no regressions
but at least we introduced ourselves
this time so we're making progress
this experiments mode use map data at
all for speed limits no
that's all machine learning based the
idea is kind of that you know the
machine learning you're thinking about
how fast you should drive is kind of the
best uh we can do and then if you want
to abide by the speed limit you should
just set the crispy to that and then I
won't exceed them
[Music]
fighting hard for comma we definitely
need competition to keep everyone on
their toes
does it try and reach that Max Speed no
it just uses it as an upper bound
[Music]
just join what fort is this going to be
available for it's oh an XSI what's up
Nick
um
so it's available for six boards the
Maverick the Bronco sport
and a few more you can go to the website
right now type in Ford
um and some linkins
was there anything very particular about
the interface of these new Fords uh I
mean what do you mean this is the
the first Fords we support
only new models will be supported
lockout's still not hacked that is
correct
Ford is one of the biggest Auto in you
yes this is kind of the last Big Brand
we didn't support it sounds very
exciting
and when we've got the F-150 we see we
have lots of ram users
[Music]
we're trying to get your RAM 2500 and
3500 it's Upstream soon uh FedEx working
on that
yeah the ram was a whole bunch of these
screws it's taller than any car we
supported it's heavier it's got
different weight distribution it's got
different steering interface
are the checks on the hybrids different
yeah so there's an issue with the Ford
hybrids in particular
um
Shane suspects it's an issue with
messages coming out of a particular
Gateway on those cars
um we had to revert them for this
release into the quality it just wasn't
up to where we wanted it so you'd get
random corruption
um
have some of the checksums and the
counters
which the uh we found the the stock
camera was very much okay with but uh
they uses this other signal called the
quality flag
it all should make it so you can live
stream right off of the comma three
yeah pretty soon with the body hopefully
uh we want the remote control to be very
good very soon it's kind of the first
step
we're kind of experimenting with the
body with the stuff like live streaming
and you know
you know stuff
inspires the improvements that It
ultimately leads will compiler to
so if we can control the body through
connect and live stream the audio and
the video and control the body that you
know likely will also end up working for
the comma 3 when it's in your car so
you should be able to connect to your
device whenever you want Sentry mode yes
install on the list
how long do you think before we can buy
a C3 install F-150 plug and play and use
it we don't really give timelines but
um there seems to be lots of interest in
the F-150 and it makes sense so we'll uh
probably put up a bounty for that
when requesting a maneuver on the
Gateway what do you mean a maneuver
thoughts on Tesla going end to end I
don't really understand their version
scheme they're going from like 11.4 to
12 and some unknown amount of time
whenever that's end to end end to end is
the only way anyway so like it makes
sense for them to go into it but we've
seen nothing from the release notes that
uh imply this is
what they're working on it's surprising
but I think they're end to end in this
case means that they are so they used to
have a classical perception and
then code planning yeah and so I think
what they're doing now is they're doing
uh so classical perception and then
machine learning planning but there's
still a human understandable
intermediate layer as far as I
understand
so it is a step closer to end to end but
I would say I think it's not I mean
elon's tweet was ambiguous but
it sounds more like what we're doing
than that I don't know that's what I
read somewhere I don't know
it might be full anyway
but either way I mean Android is the
only thing that makes sense we've been
saying this for years
anyone try out 092 driving on Master a
lot of you guys are on Master these days
there's like almost 300 of you
plaster is too reliable does third
Paradigm use overrides to punish the
model during training
Paradigm is kind of hypothetical at the
moment it's not like we've trained
anything like that but yes if we do that
yes
right now we're getting the humans in
the loop with that cool dashboard
I wish this wasn't potato quality it's
kind of a nice drive
Bloomington
California's brain Master CI hasn't
failed to build in a long time great
testing well Master CI won't
it wouldn't get pushed to master CI but
appreciate the comments about testing
testing is very important
it's why we can do so much with a small
team
[Music]
we'll do a couple more questions and
then call it a day yeah
say two more questions
anybody got anything else
complaints that you
that you want yeah anything you want us
to fix anything you want to talk about
on the blog post for zero nine two
I think the old website looked more
clean and professional
uh
yeah I mean we're constantly iterating
on the website
I think experimental mode and chill mode
should have separate Cruise speed
settings
I don't even know how that would work
that sounds confusing
here in Brazil we don't have this Bronco
the BSM is sophisticated equals
BSM
progress to Taco quote I don't know what
that means
we're getting a lot of random comments
now no questions uh
to ask questions blind no I know that's
what BSN means but that didn't make
sense in the guy's question
well so who's comma Brazil I didn't know
we had a Brazil division
[Music]
is pretty active in the community from
Brazil it was a RAV4
oh you did mean blind spot monitor the
BSM is good equal to it
I still don't understand the question uh
is there a plan release for navigating
on open pilot
you're talking about this twice now
early on the stream so
I mean do you want to tell them
yeah I mean the
there's some working for
trial branches if you want there's a few
more things as we want to do and then
we'll release it but yeah the plan is to
go not to experiment but straight to
master so as soon as you ever put in a
lab destination I will use the map
oh progress to Taco meaning do you want
an update on taco stuff uh
yeah I don't think it's time for that
maybe once okay we should navigate on
open pilot if you have points from the
corner Raiders like ev6 uh no
what's now the biggest Auto that's
unsupported
um
probably Toyota security
as far as Brands were pretty well
covered now
23 Prius looks really nice
all right guys I think if no one has any
more questions
we'll just call it there
all right guys thanks for tuning in
yeah
if you've got any complaints closing or
Discord